Transcriber: Omar Al-Shateri
المدقّق: Hossam abdelfattah
لغة أخرى تعني نسخة جديدة من الحياة.
إذا تحدثنا لغة مختلفة،
سننظر نوعا ما إلى العالم بطريقة مختلفة.
أنت الآن تسمع صوتي ولا تراني
من خلال الكلمات التي أستخدمها
نبرة الصوت وطريقة الحديث
حاول أن تخمن، كيف أبدو؟
ارفع يدك إن كنت تعتقد أنني سمين
واخفضها إن كنت تعتقد أنني نحيل.
ارفع يدك إن كنت تعتقد أنني طويل
واخفضها إن كنت تظن أنني قصير.
ارفع يدك إن كنت تعتقد أنني أبيض البشرة
واخفضها إن كنت تعتقد أنني أسمر.
نحيل، قصير، أسمر
إن حزرت صفتين من الثلاث، ارفع يدك.
أحسنتم صفقوا لأنفسكم
(تصفيق)
طبعا، حتى هذا الإنسان أيضا ليس أنا.
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته،
(ضحك)
أهلا وسهلا بكم جمهور TEDx
في هذه الليلة
وفي هذا الحدث الذي سنتحدث معكم فيه
عن ماذا لو أن لغتك تؤطر تفكيرك
معكم أخوكم عبدالرحمن باجنيد،
معيد لغة إنجليزية
بجامعة الملك سعود بن عبدالعزيز
للعلوم الصحية
(تصفيق)
فرع جدة.
حصلت على قرابة 28 جائزة
وعلى مستوى جامعات المملكة
مستوى جامعة الملك عبدالعزيز
معظمها جوائز أدبية ولغوية.
(تصفيق)
من خلال الكلمات التي أعطيتها لكم
خلف الكواليس، ونبرة الحديث.
كل شخص من الجمهور اختلف،
بعضكم قال انت سمين والآخر قال أنت قصير.
رسم تصور معين.
هذا يدلنا انه فيه علاقة وثيقة
بين اللغة والعقل
أعطيكم مثال آخر،
هل سبق وتعرفت
على شخص عبر الإنترنت
ثم جئت أول مرة وقابلته
قلت: فلان! هذا شكلك لم أتوقعه أبدا.
تصورك كان مختلف جداً
كثير، صحيح؟
لأنه من خلال المكالمة التي أجريتها،
نبرة صوتك، طريقة كلامك، الكلمات بالواتساب
...اعطى تصور معين
لكن ليس هذا موضوعنا
لم آتي اليوم لأقول لك
أن هناك ارتباط بين العقل واللغة
موضوعي اليوم: هل يا تُرى هذا الارتباط
يختلف من لغة إلى لغة؟
يعني هل الشخص الذي يتحدث اللغة العربية
كعبدالرحمن يفكر بطريقة وينظر للعالم
غير ريتشارد الذي بيتكلم باللغة الإنجليزية،
غير ليلي التي تتكلم باللغة الصينية؟
العالم فيه الآن سبعة آلاف لغة
هل كل شخص من السبعة آلاف
يفكرون بسبعة آلاف طريقة مختلفة؟
أو بطريقة واحدة فقط؟
ستقولون أكيد يفكرون بطرق مختلفة،
لأن هناك تربية وفيه أديان وفيه عادات
وقيم وتنشئة وبيئة وثقافات وتقاليد
كلها تدخل في تفكير الإنسان.
ليس هذا سؤالي.
هل تتذكرون عندما كنا نقول في الفيزياء
ثبت الضغط وثبت عامل الحرارة
بعدها أعطني القانون.
مع ثبات هذه العوامل
هل اللغة بذاتها تؤثر فينا؟
لو عندنا اثنين كلهم تربوا في نفس البيئة
نفس الأب، نفس الأم، نفس العادات
نفس التقاليد، نفس القيم، نفس التنشئة،
نفس كل شئ إلا اللغة.
شخص يتحدث العربية وشخص يتحدث الإنجليزية
هل سيفكرون بطريقة مختلفة؟
الأغلبية يقولون لا.
هذه النظرية اسمها النسبية اللغوية
نظرية النسبية اللغوية ظهرت
في ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي
على يد عالمَين، العالم إدوارد سابير
وتلميذه بنيامين لي وورف.
هذان العالمان يقولان
أن الشخص الذي يتكلم لغة معينة
تفكيره ونظرته للكون تختلف
عن شخص يتكلم لغة أخرى
كانت النظرية
في ذلك العصر ضعيفة
مافي أدلة قوية وبراهين
حتى وصلنا في السبعينات الميلادية
وصلت هذه النظرية للحضيض، وصلت للقاع
لأنه جات نظرية مضادة ومعاكسة
سموها نظرية عالمية اللغة
لنعوم تشومسكي
هذه النظرية تقول
أن كل متحدثي السبعة آلاف لغة
يفكرون بطريقة واحدة.
وكانت هي النظرية القوية
بعضكم يمكن أن يقول لماذا نحن جئنا
اليوم نتكلم عن النسبية اللغوية؟
كما قال المقدم إستاذ محمد الموسى
هل هذا الشئ منطقي يعني؟!
لأنه لحسن الحظ في السنوات الأخيرة
هناك مجموعة من العلماء
أمثال ليرا بوروديتسكي
قاموا بأبحاث ودراسات تعضد هذه النظرية
سنستعرض بعض هذه الدراسات
وبعض هذه الأمثلة
و إن شاء الله تغيرون رأيكم نهاية هذا الحدث
أغلق عينيك، الجميع يغمض عينيه
خائفين نعمل فيكم خدعة مثل البداية؟
بعض الناس فضوليين لازم يفتح عين
هرمون الفضول عنده زائد
بدون تفكير الجميع يشير
إلى اتجاه الجنوب الشرقي
بدون تفكير
الجنوب الشرقي؟
افتحوا أعينكم، انظروا إلى الأشخاص بجانبكم
مستحيل! هنا دكتور محمد الحكيم وأستاذ طراد
متعاكسين الاتجاه تماماً
(ضحك)
مثل علامة X حق TEDx
مستحيل! أنا نفسي لا أعرف أين الجنوب الشرقي
سؤال آخر
هل تفضل استخدام الجهات المطلقة
في وصف الأماكن؟
يعني عندما أقول لك:
كيف أذهب إلى جامعة سعود بن عبدالعزيز؟
تقول لي اذهب للدوار،
ثم اتجه من الدوار شرقاً
بعدها اذهب إلى ثاني منعطف غرباً
ثم ارجع إلى جهة الجنوب
أو أقول لك
أخرج من الدوار، ثاني منعطف يمين
بعدها اذهب إلى ثاني منعطف يسار
ثم إلى الدوار
الثاني أسهل؟
(نعم)
الثاني أسهل
في إحدى لغات مدينة كيب يورك شمال أستراليا
يستخدم أهلها الجهات المطلقة فقط
يعني هؤلاء ليس عندهم يمين يسار قدام وراء
عندهم شمال شرق جنوب غرب
هؤلاء يأتي أحدهم يقول لك يافلان
لو سمحت أعطني الملعقة
التي بالشمال الشرقي من الصحن
(ضحك)
تضحكون؟
لكن هي هكذا فعلاً
هل يعقل!
سألوا بنت في الخامسة من عمرها في الشارع
قالوا لها أين جهة
الجنوب الشرقي؟ مباشرة أشارت.
الموضوع بالنسبة لها كان سهل
سألوا نفس السؤال في كبرى جامعات العالم
هارفرد، وستانفرد، وجامعة العلوم الصحية
حصل نفس الذي حصل هنا
وعيهم اللغوي بسبب الكلمات
التي يستخدموها وبسبب تراكيبهم
جعل عندهم وعي أكبر بالجهات من وعينا
باللغة العربية واللغة الإنجليزية
سؤال آخر
رتب الصور التالية زمنياً
شخص يمر بمراحل حياته المختلفة
طفل، ولد، شاب، كهل
سنتفق جميعاَ أنه سيبدأ
طفل ويصبح ولد ثم شاب
ثم كهل
ابقوا هذا المثال في ذهنكم، سنرجع له
عندنا في اللغة العربية
الخال يختلف عن العم
والخالة تختلف عن العمة
في اللغة الإنجليزي عندنا uncle خال وعم
و aunt خالة وعمة
عندنا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول: الخالة بمنزلة الأم، حديث صحيح
مثَل عامي يقول: الخال خالي، والعم؟
هل نمتوا ؟
والعم؟ (ولي)
هل نقدر نفهّم شخص أجنبي يتحدث
اللغة الإنجليزية هذه المسألة أن هناك فرق
رغم إنّها كلمة واحدة
عملنا هذه التجرية في جامعة
سعود بن عبدالعزيز فرع جدة
ولتجربة هذه النظرية قمنا باختيار
محاضرَين في قسم اللغة الإنجليزية
بجامعة الملك سعود بن عبدالعزيز
للعلوم الصحية بفرع جدة
للإجاية على أسئلتنا
سألنا الشخص الأول
يرتب الصور مثل ترتيبنا السابق
والشخص الثاني يفرق بين العم والخال
بدأ يرتب وواثق جدا، رتب نفس ترتيبنا
لكن بدأ من اليسار،
ونحن بدأنا من اليمين
هل تعتقد أن كل الناس سوف
يرتبون نفس ترتيبك
نعم، طبعاً
لأنه في اللغة العربية نكتب
من اليمين ونفكر من اليمين
لذا نبدأ الماض من اليمين
ونتجه للمستقبل عكس اللغة الإنجليزية
هل الناس في مجتمعك يعطون
حقوق أكثر لشقيق الأم أو لشقيق الأب؟
هل تعرف أنهم في لغتنا مختلفَين
وأن هناك كلمات تعبر عن كل شخص؟
ليس لدينا كلمة واحدة تعبرعنهم جميعاً
إذن شخصَين مختلفَين
وأدوارهم مختلفة في المجتمع
سؤال آخر كيف سيكون تفكيرك
إن لم يكن في لغتك أرقام؟
تخيل لغتك العربية لايوجد فيها
واحد اثنين ثلاثة اربعة
لغة إنجليزية مافيها 1234
لغة البيراها في الأمازون
ليس فيها أرقام
عندهم قليل، وبعض، وكثير
وجدوا أن الوعي المالي عند هؤلاء
أقل من الوعي المالي لأشخاص
في لغة تحتوي على أرقام
تقدر تقول لقد وفرت هذا الشهر ألف وتسعمائه
وخمسة وأربعين ريال ونص
وخمسة هلَلات
لكن هو يقول أنا وفرت هذا الشهر بعض المال
الشهر الذي بعده وفّر بعض المال
لكن أكثر من الشهر الماض
وعيهم المالي كان ضعيف
بسبب لغتهم أثرت عليهم
مثال آخر:
هل المستقبل أمامك أم خلفك؟
من يتفق أن الستقبل في الأمام
والماضِ في الخلف؟
انظروا حولكم، الجميع يتفق؟
أتوقّع لا يوجد بني آدم يختلف
في هذا الشئ حتى صديقنا هذا يتفق معنا
تعرف يا بني في حالتك هذه، صاحبي تيمون
يقول: لازم ترمي ظهرك وراء الماضِ
لا لا لا يا غشيم
قف معووج وتكلّم بشكل صحيح
أصلها ارمِ الماضِ وراء ظهرك
المستقبل في الأمام والماضِ في الخلف
شيء نتفق عليه جميعاً
وجدوا في بعض اللغات أن عندهم
المستقبل في الخلف والماضِ في الأمام
نحن في تعبيراتنا اللغوية
نقول انطلق إلى الأمام
يأتيك الأستاذ طلال باسنبل مع الحماس
المستقبل أمامك وانطلق وافعل
ولا تنظر إلى الماضِ الذي فات ولن يعود
هؤلاء تعبيراتهم اللغوية تختلف
مستحيل يقول لك انطلق
إلى الأمام، لأنَّ الماضِ أمامه
ووراءه مستقبل
(تصفيق)
هل نظرتنا إلى الألوان واحدة؟
نجرب، ما هذا اللون؟
الجميع بصوت واحد
(أحمر)
وهذا اللون؟
كلهم وردي، شخص قال زهري
هل اللونين مختلفَين؟
(نعم)
مختلفَين صح؟
بعض اللغات اللونين نفس اللون
مثل عندنا نقول أخضر غامق وأخضر فاتح
أزرق غامق وأزرق فاتح
عندهم هذان اللونان أحمر غامق وأحمر فاتح
هذان اللونان، ما هما؟
أزرق غامق ، نيلي ، كحلي
والآخر؟
سماوي،أزرق فاتح، أياً كان
هل هما لونان مختلفان؟
أو درجتان مختلفان من اللون نفسه؟
في اللغة الروسية هذان ليسا نفس اللون
لو قابلت روسي وقلت له
السماء والبحر لونهما واحد
سيضحك عليك
نحن عندنا هذان نفس اللون، هو عنده العكس
عملت ليرا بوروديتسكي دراسة على الجسور
أتت بمتحدثين يتحدثوا الإنجليزية والألمانية
ومتحدثين يتحدثوا الإنجليزية والإسبانية
في اللغة الإنجليزية
لا يوجد التذكير والتأنيث
Table مذكرة أو مؤنثة؟
ولا شيء
في اللغة العربية الطاولة مؤنثة
أتت إلى الذين يتحدثون الإسبانية
وقالت لهم صِفوا لي الجسور؟
الجسور في اللغة الإسبانية مذكرة
قالوا الجسور عظماء ورائعيين وممتازين
كل الصفات التي اُستخدمت
تدل على أن الجسر ذكر
أو مذكر
ثم جائت إلى متحدثي اللغة الألمانية
وعندهم الجسور مؤنثة
وصفوها على أنّها أنثى
تخيل شخص يقول لك الجسور لطيفة وجميلة
كبري الخليج يا عسل
(ضحك)
ليست منطقية، صح؟
لغتهم الأم أثرت على طريقة
تفكيرهم في نظرتهم للأمور
سأذكر ثلاثة من نتائج اختلاف هذا التأثير
النتيجة الأولى: وجود شخصيتين
مختلفتين للإنسان
كم شخص منكم عندما يقابل
شخص يتحدث بالإنجليزية مثلاً
يجده هادئ وباللغة العربية متحمس
يجده في اللغة الإنجليزية متواضع
وفي اللغة العربية متكبر
يجد اختلاف في شخصيته بين لغة ولغة؟
تحدث، صحيح؟
بعض الناس تصل إلى انفصام في شخصيته
تجد أن شخصيته مختلفة
تماماً في الإنجليزية عن العربية
ليرا بوروديتسكي تقول أنت تفكر أقرب
إلى شخص روسي حين تتحدث اللغة الروسية
وتصرفاتك تكون قرب إلى شخص
إنجليزي حين تتحدث اللغة الإنجليزية
شارلمان يقول أن تمتلك لغة أخرى
يعني أن تمتلك روحاً أخرى
شخصية أخرى
الأثر الثاني هو
تفضيل لغة عن الأخرى
على حسب التفكير المطلوب
كم مرة كنت تتكلم بالعربية
وفجأة علقت بالإنجليزية
أو قلت نكتة بالإنجليزية
السبب؟ لأنها بالإنجليزية أحلى
النكتة هنا في الإنجليزية مفهومة
ومميزة، وفي العربي ليست مضحكة
أحياناً تقرأ نكت بالإنجليزية لا تعجبك
لكن بالنسبة للإنجليز مضحكة
تجد أحياناً لو تتحدث بأكثر من لغة
حسب التفكير المطلوب حسب الموقف
تختار اللغة التي سوف تستخدمها
النقطة الثالثة:
البحث عن لغة واحدة
لإحياء السلام في العالم
من وجهة نظر اللغويين
أن مشاكل العالم والحروب
والتطاحن سببها اختلاف لغاتنا
مما يؤدي إلى اختلاف تفكيرنا
مما يؤدي إلى حروب ومشاكل
من وجهة نظر لغوية بحتة
يقولون لو وجد لغة واحدة يتحدثها كل العالم
ستقل هذه المشاكل لأن
تفكيرنا سيكون موحد
قاعدة عامة في الترجمة تقول
أي عملية ترجمة لابد وأن يتخللها نقص
نقص في المعاني، في الكلمات،
في المشاعر أياً كان
تخيل أن هناك شخص يتحدث اللغة العربية
يريد أن يوصل رسالة
لشخص يتحدث اللغة الإنجليزية
وبينهم ناقل هو المترجم الذي لابد
أن يحدث نقص في إرسال الرسالة
وتكون الرسالة أقل من المستوى التي قيلت فيه
فهذا يحدث مشاكل
لو استطعنا أن نتكلم لغة واحدة
لن تحدث مشاكل والتفكير لن يختلف
حسب وجهة نظر اللغويين
نيلسون مانديلا يقول
إذا تحدثت مع شخص بلغةٍ
يفهمها فذلك يحرّك عقله
وإذا تحدثت مع شخصٍ
بلغته الأصلية فذلك يحرّك قلبه
وهذا الشئ الذي نريده
إذاً مادام أنها تحتوي
على هذه المعاني الجميلة
لماذا لا نتعلم لغة اخرى؟
دعونا نتعلم لغة ثانية
دعونا ننظر للأمور من زوايا متعددة
ما دام نحن ننظر من زاوية ضيقة ننظر
من زوايا متعددة ونغير من طريقة تفكيرنا
واحد من علماء علم تعدد اللغات
الذي يستخدم أبحاثه على متعددي اللغات
بعد أن عمل هذه الأبحاث
قال تستطيع سماع الموسيقى من سماعة واحدة،
كالسماعة الصغيرة الممزقة
وتستطيع سماع الموسيقى من ستيريو كامل
نفس الشيء بالنسبة للغة
تستطيع أن تنظر للكون، تعبر عن نفسك،
تعبرعن أصدقائك، عن مجتمعك
تنظر للكون من زاوية واحدة وبلغة واحدة
وتستطيع أن تنظر من زوايا كثيرة جداً
وبلغات مختلفة وطرق تفكير مختلفة
إذاً اسمحوا لي أرجع
إلى سؤالنا في هذا المؤتمر
ماذا لو أن؟
ماذا لو أن العالم كله يتحدث لغة واحدة
أمريكا روسيا أسبانيا
ألمانيا كوريا السعودية
الجميع يتحدث لغة واحدة فقط
ماذا لو أننا نتحدث لغتين
ثلاث، خمس، سبع، عشر
ما هو التغيير الذي يمكن أن يطرأ
على تفكيرنا، على نظرتنا للكون،
نظرتنا للعالم، تفاهمنا، تواصلنا مع بعض
هذه أسئلة لن أجيب عليها
أترككم أنتم تجيببون عليها
هذا كان وقتي شكراً لكم
السلام عليكم
(تصفيق)